tenemos un clavadista que se avienta a
un acantilado que está a 85 pies sobre
el agua si la velocidad inicial del
clavadista es de menos cinco pies hombre
segundo es decir cinco pies sobre
segundo hacia abajo y la aceleración de
la gravedad es de menos treinta y dos
pies sobre segundo al cuadrado 32 pies
sobre uno cuadrado hacia abajo la
gravedad te cala hacia abajo que por
cierto esto realmente quiere decir que
por cada segundo que pase nuestra
velocidad de aumentar 32 pies sobre
segundo entonces me pregunta y lo que
quiero resolver en este problema es
cuánto tiempo pase el clavadista en el
aire antes de que entré al agua
y bueno lo primero que sería bastante
bueno definir es el tiempo en el que
pasa el clavadista en el aire por lo
tanto de una vez vamos a definir a t
como el tiempo que pasa el clavadista en
el aire el tiempo que pasa el clavadista
en el aire muy bien esto es muy
importante y bueno lo primero que quiero
apuntar aquí son algunos de los datos
que me dan lo primero que me dicen es
que la velocidad inicial es de menos 5
pies sobre segundo déjame ponerlo aquí
la velocidad inicial es igual a menos
pies entre segundo porque es una
velocidad que va hacia abajo es decir el
traba dista en lugar de lanzarse al aire
hacia arriba se lanzó el directamente
hacia abajo con esta velocidad y bueno
después vamos a ver cómo se podría
calcular pues la velocidad final si te
das cuenta la velocidad final tiene que
ser esta velocidad que ya tenemos es
decir menos cinco pies sobre segundo
pero a esta velocidad final vamos a
aumentarle algo o más bien va a
disminuir algo porque estamos viendo que
es una velocidad que va hacia abajo y
que es esto que le vamos a tener que
quitar
bueno pues fíjate lo que nos dice la
aceleración de la gravedad es de menos
32 pies sobre segundo al cuadrado y es
justo lo que yo te decía que por cada
segundo que pase nuestra velocidad va a
aumentar hacia abajo 32 pies sobre
segundo por lo tanto para obtener la
velocidad final en el momento justo en
el que tocamos el agua vamos a tener que
restarle 32 pies sobre segundo al
cuadrado por la cantidad de segundos que
pasamos en el aire esto por el tiempo
que pasemos en el aire entre más tiempo
pasemos en el aire nuestra velocidad va
a ser más grande
es decir la aceleración de la gravedad
por el tiempo y fíjate que las unidades
concuerdan porque aquí tengo pies sobre
segundo y aquí me quedaría pies sobre
segundo cuadrado por segundo lo cual no
va a quedar pies sobre segundo que es
también velocidad es decir nuestro
clavadista se lanzó hacia abajo a una
velocidad de 5 pies sobre segundo por lo
tanto es una velocidad que va hacia
abajo y después la gravedad nos va a
seguir lanzando hacia abajo por lo tanto
cada segundo que pase a partir de que
nos lanzamos con esta velocidad nuestra
velocidad va a ir aumentando va a ir
aumentando 32 pies sobre segundo por
cada segundo que pasa es decir la
aceleración de la gravedad por eso me
queda que mi velocidad final es la
velocidad inicial ya esto le aumente o
más bien le resten porque estamos
hablando de velocidades hacia abajo la
gravedad por el tiempo que pasemos en el
aire y bueno ya que tengo la velocidad
inicial y ya que tengo la velocidad
final pues seremos bueno calcular
también la velocidad promedio para
danone ya de más o menos qué velocidad
voy a tener durante todo el recorrido y
está genial esto porque matamos dos
pájaros de un tiro' estamos aprendiendo
por una parte física y por la
y realmente quiero llegar un problema
que tenga que ver construcciones
cuadráticas de hecho vamos a tener que
aplicar la fórmula general de ecuaciones
de segundo grado pero bueno por ahorita
vamos a pensar en el promedio equipar
esto me voy a tomar la suma entre estos
dos valores la velocidad final y la
velocidad inicial y la voy a dividir
entre 2 y cuánto es esto menos 5 menos 5
es menos 10 y después menos 32 por el
tiempo entre 2 ojo ya estoy
multiplicando por el tiempo y esto me
queda menos 10 entre 2 lo cual es menos
5 y menos 32 entre 2 lo cual es menos 16
por el tiempo menos 5 menos dieciséis
tema esta velocidad promedio me va a
servir bastante para que yo pueda
resolver un problema porque si tú te
acuerdas de tus fórmulas de física la
distancia es igual a la velocidad oa la
rapidez por el tiempo y es justo aquí
cuando voy a utilizar el último dato que
nos dan nos dicen que la distancia que
va a pasar nuestro clavadista en el aire
son 85 pies que es la distancia que
tiene mi acantilado por lo tanto ya
tengo la distancia ya tengo por aquí la
rapidez la rapidez es exactamente lo
mismo a mi velocidad promedio por eso la
saqué
y ahora puedo despejar el tiempo y me va
a quedar que la distancia es 85 que por
cierto la cual la voy a poner negativa
porque vamos a ir hacia abajo es una
distancia que vamos a recorrer hacia
abajo es igual a quien a la rapidez pero
quedamos que la rapidez es la velocidad
promedio que es menos 5 - 16 te dejamos
ponerle hasta aquí menos 5 - 16 stem
esta es mi rapidez entonces menos cinco
menos dieciséis stem ya esto hay que
multiplicarlo por el tiempo y ojo esto
está dado en metro sobre segundo y
después multiplicamos por el tiempo pero
el tiempo es justo lo que queremos es
decir es nuestra incógnita por lo tanto
lo que estamos haciendo es multiplicando
esta velocidad promedio por nuestra
incógnita tiempo y entonces ya llegó a
esta ecuación menos 85 es igual a menos
5 menos 16 t todo esto multiplicado por
t y bueno sí ya tengo una ecuación con
una incógnita pues vamos a ver que me
quedan si yo distribuir 7 por esto que
esté dentro del paréntesis y me queda
menos 85 es igual a menos 5 por tema
menos 16 por tm por tel
es decir
6 t cuadrada y en este momento es cuando
se te ocurre la idea de que podemos usar
la fórmula general tenemos una ecuación
de segundo grado por lo tanto vamos a
igualar la cero y para eso vamos a sumar
85 de ambos lados de la ecuación del
lado izquierdo no queda 0 y del lado
derecho 1 queda menos 16 de cuadrada
menos 5 tm 85 esto sí acomodamos todos
los términos primero lo que tiene que
ver con t cuadrada después lo que tiene
que ver con tema y después lo que tiene
que ver con la constante menos 16 de
cuadrada menos cinco temas 85 y bueno ya
tenemos una fórmula cuadrática y
entonces por qué no aplicamos la fórmula
general de ecuaciones de segundo grado
para que yo pueda resolver esta fórmula
cuadrática que dice menos ven menos ven
ojo esta fórmula ya que las deben saber
menos b es decir menos menos cinco más
menos la raíz cuadrada debe cuadrada es
decir de menos cinco de cuadrados los
cuales 25 menos cuatro por a por ser
menos cuatro por an pero a vale menos 16
por c pero se va el 85
entonces me quedan menos 4 x menos 16
por 85
todo esto dividido entre 2 am pero aval
de 16 menos 16 por lo tanto por 232
negativo y bueno pues vamos a resolver
esto me queda cinco más menos 25 x menos
4 x menos 16 por 85 déjenme calcular de
aquí menos 4 x menos 16 por 85 cuántos
esto no sé bien para cuánto me sirva
esta calculadora y cuánto me sirvan a
mejor de algo a mano estos menos por
menos me da más aquí esto me va a quedar
más y después es 4 por 85 lo cual es ok
mejor para no tardar mucho lo voy a
hacer rapidísimo aquí la calculadora 25
más 4 por 85 por 16 4 por 16 por 80
todo esto cuánto es esto y bueno la
multiplicación de 4 por 16 por 85 es
5.440 y si a esto le sumamos 25 que a
5.465 ahora vamos a buscar el botón de
raíz cuadrada
ahora vamos a sacar la raíz cuadrada
esto y me queda 73 puntos 92 la raíz
cuadrada de lo que teníamos eran 73
puntos 92 entonces ya si quitamos la
raíz cuadrada y haciendo todas estas
operaciones me queda 73 puntos 92 déjame
borrar mi raíz cuadrada con la que me
adelante y solamente me voy a quedar con
mi resultado que es 73.9 y bueno esto es
dividido entre menos 32
ahora bien vamos a resolver para ti
primero tomando el signo más y después
tomando el signo menos y me quedan cinco
más 73 puntos 92 entre menos 30 y 2 573
punto 92
esto es 78.9 78 puntos 92 78.9 entre
menos 32 38.9 entre menos 32 ese sería
mi primera respuesta
la segunda respuesta es 5 menos 73
puntos 92
esto me da menos 68.9 menos 68.9 y está
dividido entre menos 32 si estamos bien
menos 68.9 menos 5 me dan sí claro menos
73.9 y esto es dividido entre menos 32 y
menos entre menos me da más ahora bien
quiero que aquí te des cuenta de algo
muy importante este que tenemos aquí es
un número negativo sea lo que sea que me
salga de dividir 78.9 entre menos 32 me
da un número negativo y eso no puede ser
mi respuesta porque estamos hablando de
tiempo y el tiempo no puede ser negativo
no podríamos ir hacia atrás en el tiempo
por lo tanto mi respuesta y hace que
68.9 entre 32 vamos a calcular la 68.9
entre 32
esto es igual a 2.15 el tiempo que estoy
buscando es la solución positiva de esta
fórmula general que es 2.15 segundos y
perfecto ya llegué a mi resultado